Real Housewives of New York City star
LuAnn de Lesseps checks herself into
rehab I'm just trying to get back on my
feet
the 52 year old reality star announced
her plan to check into an alcohol
treatment center on Facebook Friday
after she was arrested in Palm Beach
Florida on Christmas Eve writing in part
after the events of last Saturday night
in Palm Beach
I am truly embarrassed I have decided to
seek professional guidance and will be
voluntarily checking into an alcohol
treatment center ET confirmed luan was
arrested and taken into Palm Beach
County Jail at 1:25 a.m. over the
holiday weekend and was later charged
with disorderly intoxication resisting
arrest and battery on a law enforcement
officer the former countess has had a
tough year the arrest comes just months
after her divorce from husband Tom
D'Agostino was finalized after just
seven months of marriage where a
discombobulated housewives family and
back in April her 22 year old daughter
Victoria was arrested and charged with
driving under the influence in Sag
Harbor New York
[Music]